i think we did like 400 500 runners what
yeah
what that was you or someone somebody
else it has to be me i'm the stunt
double
there's no stunt double for the stunt
wait is there hey welcome back to
another episode of stunt women react we
are here with lauren mary kim
hey who is a stunt woman extraordinaire
specialized in fights you've done some
crazy wire work you've been on a bunch
of really cool projects
so we have a bunch of really cool clips
both from your work and some stuff that
we want to show to you
so we'd love to hear your thoughts and
have you break some things down share
your stories and experiences with
everyone here so
let's jump in
it seems like daredevil was so long ago
i think it was
four or five years ago yeah it seems
like so long ago
the nobu fight with daredevil is one of
my favorites your
city you don't know you don't excuse us
so is this you here yes very cool we
shot that one in the middle of the night
on a cold
new york night
micah carnes who doubled nobu he had to
do like a kick off my chest
and then kick daredevil in the face oh
jeez which was you know i'm a girl with
boobs so
that was not easy you have to be planted
and grounded for that right exactly
but it can't look like you're ready for
it exactly i know it kind of looks like
i did wait a little god damn it
i think i tried to do like a ghost tip
so dark too so that kind of helped me
you just gotta do it a whole bunch until
it looks right i guess yeah yeah and
sometimes it takes a long time
was this shot uh in sequence or was it
shot and covered no i think we did
pieces actually you know what we did a
bunch of masters for this one as well
what's your preferred way of working
pieces
pieces and saves the performer for sure
eledy young has a black belt in karate
so she was able to pick up choreography
really fast and on the day
she was phenomenal and then we started
training together so we started actually
moving
a lot of likes so sometimes we would
watch takes and we're like is that me is
that you
so why would you swap out to another
person if the actress also knows martial
arts
um because she doesn't always get the
rehearsal time like i do because she's
always like shooting scenes
and sometimes they can't do the flip or
the falls and so that's where we come in
how often do you find yourself on a new
show if i'm on a run of a show like
daredevil that's like
six months it just varies depending on
the length of each show
so is this one of your scenes right here
yes i fight all the defenders in this
episode
so i fight luke cage daredevil and
jessica jones and iron fist
she gets picked up by jessica jones
thrown face first into a wall
[Laughter]
or somewhere somebody else it has to be
me i'm the stunt double okay
there's no stunt double for the stunt
time
wait is there sometimes okay only
because they have to save the main
double so they'll bring in someone to do
something gnarlier
okay it looks like you get wrecked right
here oh yeah that's not great this is so
good
walk us through this here what's that
right here i'm on a wire
and basically i'm doing a butterfly it's
a wushu move where your legs kick up and
you literally look like a butterfly in
the air
got you and that helps the momentum of
me to face the wall so i don't actually
hit my face on the wall but i actually
brace myself with the wall with my arms
okay so there's a little trick
we did there was it like a double wire
setup where one is
pulling you into the scene i think we
did have a traveler on that but not like
the best rigger
to know the exact setup we obviously met
it are they hiding pads in the shadows
down yeah i think we did have
a pad that was painted to look like the
ground usually okay with something big
like this right
you don't want to do all right take two
three four five six seven right i think
we did like
two or three on this one and is that up
to the stunt coordinator
versus the director is there there's a
fine line there or
do you keep getting it until you get it
well usually the coordinator asks you if
you can do another one but yeah
it's up to the director a if he thinks
he got it b
the stunt coordinator if he thinks that
they got it and if it's usable
how much say do you have it as a stunt
performer if you've done it two or three
times you hit yourself you're kind of
hurting you think you had it taken there
and you're just like
it's not safe it's not feeling safe how
much say do you have in the beginning of
my career i probably wouldn't say
anything ever
now that i've been in the industry a lot
longer now if there is a
like a gag that i felt that was
literally killing me i think i would say
something we have to watch out for
ourselves and this is our livelihood
if you wreck us on a job we may not be
able to work for another like how many
months
and so that director's not paying my
bills yeah but
there's also that element of like you
have to be tough there's a time when to
say
you know enough is enough hey this is
the part where we ask you guys for
comments i'm not gonna ask you guys for
cool stunt scenes or fight scenes i'm
gonna ask you guys
for guests you'd love to see in the show
so please leave a suggestion down below
for people you would like us to reach
out to to see if they would like to be
on
stunt men or women react
this seems familiar i actually doubled
emily swallow as the armorer and i
actually got to do this entire fight
that's you right there yeah that's so
that's all me actually
dang that was probably one of the most
strenuous fights i've ever had to do
because of the armor yes okay and the
helmet as a warner we never did it as
pieces we did the whole fight from top
to bottom
i think we did like 400 500 runners what
yeah what because we shot so many
different angles
how do you feel about that because i
died i died
yeah how do you keep your energy up for
400 takes
i think i had red bull or how many how
many days did you spend shooting this
scene
one what that's really good for one day
yeah oh my god yeah
it was a second unit day the director
dave filoni he's like
the god of star wars he actually
directed this scene and he really wanted
to get the entirety of it in every
moment and he was very detailed with
everything so
he did such a good job directing this
dave felloni isn't necessarily an action
guy right he comes from animation
actually
and he's a really good illustrator
creator sweet so he knows he knows
movement and you know yeah
he knows camera yeah so when you have
someone like that as your
director for second unit how does that
differ than say like having a stunt
coordinator step in and do second unit
directing
well usually the stunt coordinator
shoots like a previous they have an idea
of how
it should be edited so they shoot
towards the edit with a mandalorium
they like to get a lot of different
angles so they can really choose and
see which one is the best for each
moment they're very particular with what
their look is so that's why they shoot
so many different angles and then we had
to do positive contact it was hard for
me to hit the guys
you know you're always taught to like
not hit people but they're like now just
jamming the leg just hit him in the face
and i'm like oh my god
did the stormtrooper armor actually help
them take the hits yeah and so the guys
were like hit me
hit me harder i can't feel it so i'm
like ah so it's freaking out a little
bit that's pretty cool
yeah so when you were shooting those
scenes in mandalorian was that on a
fully built set or was that on
the virtual set that was actually a set
they built
so most of the time we did shoot on the
volume but this one they actually
created
like an old-fashioned set could any of
you see out of your masks
the guys know because anytime i hit them
in the face the helmet would like turn
so then they're like moving and like
guessing that i'm there
did your costumes break much from that
the stormtroopers broke constantly
really constantly mine i think was
pretty
good because i wasn't taking a lot of
hits but it was just super restrictive
because i had different
straps so like i couldn't easily take it
off breathing was like the hardest thing
and then the fogging of course this
brings up a very important question
how practical is the mandalorian armor
would you rock it or would you change it
i mean the helmet obviously i think
protects you from a lot
no i think it's pretty practical i just
don't know about the furry little
shoulder thing that would just make you
really hot and it made me hot so i don't
know what the point what that is
she's working it just looks cool it just
looks badass i just realized this
is kali slash for the people who don't
know what kali is
can you explain or describe what cauli
is kali
or escrima is also like a filipino
martial arts
that dates way back so much history so
many different variations
in that style so it's like a lot of
stick fighting a lot of weapon work but
we also do open hand fighting as well
you would think fighting with two sticks
is like oh it's easy you just hit them
like this but no
there's like ways to hit the hand with
the bunt side of the weapon
there's disarming there is just endless
endless knowledge in that martial arts
it's best known from
dan and asando because he was bruce
lee's best friend
so dan you said is your guru yes can you
say that can we
is that yeah yeah yeah you can see it
that's amazing
we have a clip from game of death where
dan fights bruce lee
i would love to just get your your take
on that on that
[Music]
he was a huge influence as i started to
get into martial arts so i did my own
game of death
where i fight in each martial art that i
trained in yeah
so this is silat sila is an indonesian
martial art
it's very similar to capoeira so there's
a lot of trapping
and then we do a lot of groundwork and
something that's different than like
other martial arts and we actually sit
on our butt
and we'll fight from the ground
i like to transition from the rooftop to
the dojo yeah so each character
hits me into a new scene that's awesome
and so this is taekwondo
this is my actually my first martial art
i ever trained in
filming these kind of fight scenes how
often do you get hit well i hire
the best people so never really okay
and this is amy you guys know where
you're at johnston we did a kung fu
wushu fight
and this is my second martial art i
trained
you're going from like a low stance to
jumping it's just physically draining
did you choreograph this yeah me and amy
choreographed this one so when you're
choreographing a fight what's your
thought process
well first we think about any cool moves
that we want to display
and then uh we try to put like a
skeleton of a fight we like just start
moving and fighting each other
and then like see what works and what
doesn't but that's not how every fight
is choreographed because sometimes you
have to go by story
so you have to think about those
elements as well when you think of a
script but for my projects i think about
more
moves that i want to showcase because
this is my creative outlet
and i don't have a script got you so
when you're working on the flow and
it's like okay throw this and you're
going to block it like this and it goes
over here
so you know you're thinking about that
for film so like what makes a good flow
well honestly jeff amato was the
choreographer for the born identity and
so what i learned from him is like
sometimes he's like just throw something
at me just try hitting me and then he'll
naturally
move with what you give him and so
that's what i try to emulate from him
because it's something that's natural
what feels good and then from there you
can dissect
the end's not out but i have half of it
already shot if you want to check it out
on my youtube channel
sweet okay this is not an ad segment
we're working on a new video because you
guys left some comments in the previous
video remember when we reacted to
birdemic
i've imagined my whole life without
watching this well guess what we are
trying to fix those visual effects so be
sure to subscribe to this channel so
that you'll be the first to know
when that video drops
thank you so much for watching this guys
we had a lot of fun lauren thank you so
much
for joining us really really appreciate
you if you guys want to follow lauren's
work she has her own youtube channel
lauren mary kim there's a link in the
description below you can check out her
stuff
inspired by old bruce lee and all the
cool new stuff in between up to this
moment so
you do really awesome stuff thank you so
much for coming down thanks for having
me guys